this video is sponsored by
blinkist it doesn't take much a picture
a song a scent a breeze at just the
right temperature with just the right
amount of force suddenly memories flash
through our head clicked on by the
cursor of these familiar experiences old
files open often with an intense
poignancy longing regret Delight or
whatever else we watch them play people
places things feelings states of who we
were at least who we believe we
were in many ways we are our memories if
you were given the choice to either live
for thousands of years but every day all
of your memories would be erased or live
for 50 years and all of your memories
would remain fully intact and consistent
which would you choose for most of us I
believe the choice is obvious 50 years
with clear consistent memories provides
the Richer more meaningful life perhaps
perhaps in this dichotomy it provides
the only Rich meaningful life but what
does this mean about what we derive
value from the meaning we form from
ourselves our identity is of course not
merely physical it's the ability of our
mind to retain and provide subjective
continuity a tracking of our past that
we ceaselessly have access to in the
present what if an old image of yourself
of your friends or the sensation of a
familiar Breeze with the scent of a
place you've been many times
didn't open anything no memories at
least no clear consistent ones the files
and folders have been trashed with no
backup not only that but no new memories
can be formed either who would you be
what would this mean would there be a
you for some of us this isn't a thought
experiment or hypothetical it is or will
become reality our memories will be lost
daily momentarily from our entire life
[Music]
the term dementia refers to a group of
symptoms that impair memory thinking and
other General functions typically
dementia is associated with memory loss
dementia can be caused by many diseases
and conditions the leading cause however
is Alzheimer's disease as many as 60 to
80% of cases of dementia are caused by
Alzheimer's it is also the seventh
leading cause of death in America in
general according to the Alzheimer's
Association 10% of 65-year-olds have
Alzheimer's
that percentage continues to increase
significantly with age and due to the
increasing number of older people as a
result of advancements in medicine and
Technology cases of Alzheimer's are
significantly
increasing the cause of Alzheimer's is
still mostly unknown the main
characteristic however is abnormal
protein deposits in the brain two
proteins called ameloid and toao form
plaques around and cause Tangles within
brain cells eventually causing them to
die as the cells die the neurons in
their Network become disconnected and
parts of the brain shrink the correlated
functions of the brain deteriorate
alongside and dementia sets
in there are seven stages of dementia
the first two go by mostly unnoticed
minor forgetfulness and occasional
difficulty finding the right words in
the third and fourth stages symptoms
become increasingly noticeable
significant and interfering
forgetfulness difficulty forming in
completing sentences decreasing ability
to manage daily tasks and keep up with
events and other General dysfunction in
stages 5 and six severe cognitive
decline takes place the Mind begins to
take the individual from themselves
significant memory loss occurs confusion
about oneself and one's environment
major personality changes inability to
accomplish basic tasks delusions and
hallucinations by stage seven dementia
essentially takes everything that is
left the recognition of family members
and oneself language skills bodily
function what remains is total
disorientation and dysfunction at this
point the world has lost nearly all
symbolic meaning the ability to label
Define recognize and recall things is
gone and these things from the
perspective of the mind is all the world
is the individual is now completely a
drift in a shrinking sea of evaporating
brain cells until finally the sea dries
up enough for no life to
remain putting aside the gruesome hor
details of this very real experience for
very real people it is both deeply
profound and deeply unsettling to
consider dementia's implications what it
suggests about who we are and what it
means to exist and derive meaning from
existence proportional to the degree in
which dementia dims the light of
Consciousness and selfhood within the
affected it illuminates the delicacy and
abstractness of these things for the
unaffected in 1995 American artist
William UT molan was diagnosed with
Alzheimer's at age 61 following his
diagnosis over the subsequent 5 years
into and throughout the stages of his
dementia UT molan painted a now famous
series of
self-portraits in these portraits one
can observe the internal effects of
dementia depicted visually how the
affected person's self-perception
autonomy and symbolic understanding of
the world changes and erodes over time
the portraits start out with detail and
accuracy but soon they become abstract
containing unusual colors and shaping
until finally in the last portraits they
dip into nothing more than grungy shaded
circles with what can maybe be made out
to be the shadows of what was once a
nose or a brow at some point throughout
the process it can be assumed that utam
molan loses comprehension of the
significance of the portraits but to the
outside Observer they reveal the
fragility and Abstract underlying nature
of selfhood memories and cognitive
function what are we without our
memories without the ability to remember
accurately without the ability to form
memories without certain aspects of our
brain in general recalling a memory is
in some sense like watching a video the
video though it was produced in the past
is and can only be watched right now
memories are always in the present
remembering is always a present act
unlike a video however with memories
there is no consistent distinct and
tangible record of them we can of course
corroborate our memories with others
with trackable events or with external
proof but for most of life's events in
which there are no Witnesses who can
provide a testimony or there are
conflicting testimonies or there are no
clear facts or evidence our past is
accessible to us solely through our
memories but if our memories can be this
fragile this susceptible how much can we
trust them in
general a common symptom of dementia is
forming false memories these are
memories of a events and things that
never happened or didn't happen in a way
that one beliefs they did but false
memories are not exclusive to those
affected by dementia they can and likely
do occur in
everyone in a study in 1994 conducted by
psychologist Elizabeth Loftis
participants were asked to describe a
specific event from their childhood
getting lost in a shopping mall
participants then proceeded to describe
the event with great detail the issue is
that none of the participants had
actually ever gotten lost in a mall
it was merely suggested to them in a
question asked by the psychologist
conducting the study 25% of the
participants however formed entire
confabulated memories of this event
there are also many other studies like
this studies that demonstrate to a
statistical significance the phenomenon
of false memory formation as a result of
things like suggestibility mislabeling
information and the projection of one's
current views or desires onto past
[Music]
events how many of our memories are
false memor memories confabulations
generated out of our desire for
something other than the truth out of
jealousy shame hope confidence a
changing in personal views and values
out of ineptitude incredulousness out of
cognitive biases there are so many blind
spots in the mind the mind is more like
one big blind spot with one tiny
Spotlight like a photocopy of a
photocopy of a photocopy each instance
of remembering a thing also remembers
the previous instance of remembering ing
the thing sometimes solely the previous
instance each instance potentially
losing detail and accuracy connective
tissue to the real experience we are all
playing a lifelong game of telephone
with ourselves about ourselves we are
all demented in some
sense Alzheimer's and Dementia are so
unsettling and horrifying not only
because of the terrible prospective
firsthand experience but also because of
what it reveals about our existence in
general we are passengers to our body
bodies Our Minds the universe we are
inextricably contained inside the clump
of Jell-O like fat inside our skull and
our identities are fragile constructions
made within this out of the imprecise
shapes of memories synaptic connections
vulnerable to being ripped
apart the kinds of questions one might
ask who suffers from later stage
dementia aren't so dissimilar from the
kinds of questions one might ask broadly
when considering the implications of
dementia when considering the origins
and Prospects of existing inside a mind
where am I what am I
doing what am
[Music]
I this video was sponsored by blinkist
Marissa set a goal for herself to read
one book a month 2 months in she was on
track almost through her second book but
there was a problem one of the books was
pretty uninteresting discouraged not
wanting to just read for the sake of
reading but wanting to learn from and
engage in books that she was interested
in Marissa sought out a solution when
looking up the next book she was
planning on reading how to know a person
by David Brooks Marissa came across the
perfect solution blinkist an app where
you can learn from over 6,500
non-fiction books and podcasts in Just
Around 15 minutes each Marissa signed up
and immediately was able to explore and
learn from how to know a person
discovering key insights from the book
about working through relationships with
less ego understanding the complexities
of other people and ways in which to
better talk and connect with others this
was exactly what Marissa was interested
in and now thanks to blinkist she was
able to easily determined that this book
was one that she wanted to read the
complete version of she did the same
thing for tons of other titles across a
wide range of categories and was able to
curate and refine the perfect reading
list for herself not only that but she
was able to engage in countless other
books alongside which she would have
never thought of or had the time to
explore otherwise during her commutes
walks and while doing chores around the
house Marissa was was able to use
blinkist to easily fill small moments
with big insights blinkist was such a
GameChanger Marissa convinced her entire
friend group to get blinkist as well and
through blinket feature blankest spaces
the whole group easily organized and
shared titles amongst each other
accelerating their learning even further
you could do the same and get 25% off
blinket annual premium membership and a
7-Day free trial by using the link in
the description and of course as always
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
[Music]